>> Gg: WCOME BACK.I ASK AS A GE
STY EXCITES YOMOST?
IT'SIME FO--
>> T AUDNCE DECIDES THE STORY!
[CHEERS ANAPPLAUSE]
>> Greg: I GOING TO PRENT
TWO TOPICSND WHICHER GET
THE ST APPLAUSE AT'S THE
ORY 'RE GOING TO DO.SO THE FIR
GR 2.9IN THE THIRD QRTER
SHOWING HO F T ECONOMY IN 2023 .
SO BY SHOWF PLAUSE WHO WANTS
US TO DOHE STORY?
[CLAPS ]
>>reg: SECONOPTION
SCNTISTS SAY SRT MEN OF
PSHOPA I CAN AND NARCISSIIC TDE.
HEERS AND APPLSE]
>> Gg: A RIGHT, ALL RIT,
ALL GHT.
YOU OPLE A MONSTERS T
STORY TWO  IS.
GO THING I'M 6'2" OTHERWE
TH STORYIGHTAKME UNCOMFORTABLE.
BUT A UDY OUT OF POLD, YES,
IT'S A POLL OF POLS.
SOUGHT TO INSTIGATE IF SHORTER
DUDES ARE AGGRESVE ANDOM
NEING  ORDER TO COMPENSATEFOR H
CHILEN'S DEPARENT.RESEARCHERS TD
PEOP FOR THE SO-CALL DK
TRIAD OF PERSONALITY TRAITS NAHS
SCSM IE THMANILATION AND
EXOITATION OF OTRS, OR AS
CA IT FUTURNS OUT A NK WAS FOUN
BETWEEN ALL REE AITS AND
PEOP WHO WERE DISSATISFI
TH THEIR HEIGH
INTHER WORDS, [BEP] LISH
IENTISTS, YOU N'KNOW
[BEP].
HUH?
YEAH
[BEP] U AGAIN.[CHEERS D APAUSE]
TWICE BUFOR E AMERICAN
PERSPECTIVE WEO TO OUR HEIGHT
CORRESNDEN
GREG THERE ISEVIDENCE
THAT SRT M ARE EL OR
MANILATIVE OR UP TO NO GOOD.AND
YPTOREAL ESTATINVEING
AND HOW TO SCOREITH WOMEN SEND
$5 TO JOE DEVi CARE OF FOX
NE NEW YORK NEW YO.YOU CAN'T LO
'S GUARAIED.
BACK TO YOU,REG.
HEERAND APPLAUSE]
Greg: TYRUSTHIS BEGS THE QUEST
STUD
IS IT TO SHOW BIGOY AGNST SHORT?
ORHE FLAWS OF SHORT PEOPLE?
>> Tus: , THIS II'VE GOT
TOAKA DEADLI AND'VE
SMOKED AWAALL  REARCH
NEY.
ERE  NWAY TO DTHIS, WE'LL CA IT.
YOU GIVE TM A PEN ANA PAPER
D GO OUTN THE REET, EXCUSE
ME, SIR, YOU ARE HE SHORT.
THE NVERSATION'S AEADYOING
WNHILL FROM THERE.
AND THEN THEASK YOU
AGAVATING QUESTIS TOET Y
UPT.AND THEN Y REACT ANGER AND
LIKE, UHUH JUST  I TUGHT.
IT'S STUPID.
I S PREPARED TTALK ABOUT
FIAL RESPONSIBILY AND I'M SO
TID OF YOU GUYS FAING FOR
THIS ERYIME.I DON'T OW H MANY F
PRESSIONS I HA TMAKE, APPARENT
ING OUT ME.
BUT WHEN I NEEYOU TO CP FOR
ME
KAGOT  ALLNFORMATION, WE
WE READYO TALK ABOUT FISCAL
RESPSIBILITY.HOW LONG ARE WGOIN
ABOUT SHORMAD PEOPLE?DON'T YOU .
ONE GHT WE TK ABOUT FIAL
REONSIBILITY
>> Kat: AND E FA WE ULD
RATH TALK ABOUT FIAL
RESPSIBILITY IS DENITE NOT
BECAE WE'RE TOO WOIED TO
LK AUT THIS IN FRO OF A
SHORT LITTLE VDICTE MAN.
READHIS STUDAND I WALIKE, MY DI.
BUT I WOULDN SAYHAT.
>> Greg: NO.
TOTE.
>> G: THAT'S ACTUALLY A OTE
FROM EMILY
>> KatYEAH'EM WILL I WTED
MEO SAY THAT.SHE WANT MNOT TO S
FROMOU.
>>reg:MILY NO NGER ON THE
SHOW
DA CAN YOUMAGINE IF TH D
IS SRY FROM OVERIGHT PEOPLE WHOR
RIABLE UNLIKUSMEAN,
WE'RBORNHIS WAY,O QUOTE
MADONNA.>> Dana:ET'S SEE.IF THE
HUNGRY PEOPL YEA THAT
PROBLY WLDN'WORK.I DO THINK TT A
PRUCT OLLYWOOD.YOU OWTOM UISE I
SHORT.>> Greg: HIS.
>> Da: HS KE CSHING ,
RIGHT, VERY CCESSFUL.
GR GUTFE, KING OF TE
NIGH[CHEERS AND APAUSE]
>> Greg: YEA>> Dana:ND NOT A SET
>> Kat: ALHE CES ABOUT IS
TH PEOPLCLAPPED HIM JU
NOW.
>> Da: I TOO, PREPED FOR
FISCAL RESPONSIBILY SO I'M
STRUGGLING.
>> Tus: I'M SORRY Y ONE SECOND.
WE'LGEBACK TO E CHRIMAS
PAY.
IS PSES ME OFF BECSE YOU
KNOW W TOMRUZ IS SO
SUCCESSFUL>> W?
>> Tyr: BEUSE HE NDS AIG
Y TOEAT UPN EVERY MOVITO
LO STRONG JUST LK KE THE
SHORTE MAN WHO'SHE KING
COMEDY NEEDS REAY LARGE SIDE
KICK>> Dana: SEE YOUR INT.
>> Tus: REASON W YOU
DOT SEE HISMILING IS THE SHADOW
RK.
RICULO.
Greg: WOWTHERREAL LOT
HATRED TOWAS THE ORT.
GUY LEADS ME TO BIGGEST
QUESTI THE IS NO SHORT
PERSON'S MEMENAND IT SMS
ME I  THE TGET OF A L
OF HATE SPCH AROD HERE
I EL LIKE THERCOULD BE
REATON MY FE.
>> G: THEY'RE INCITING VIOLENCEU
EN I READ TH STORY AND THEY
TALKED ABO, WHATAS THE TERM,THE
SOUNDS QUITEAMILIAR D I
THOUGHWE CLD NAME THIS SHO
RK TRIAD ELAMAON POI.
BEUSIT'S REALLHITTING
NUMBERF THPOINTS.
DON'T ALLY KNOW MUCHBOUT
TH BECSE I SIX FT TALL
BUT FOR HERSI INK  WOULD
BE UNFR TO BE JUDGASED
SOLELY ON YOUR HEIT AND ON
SHOW OF GO FAITH I WILHAVE
THE UNCEGET D OFHE HEIGHTESTRIC.
HEERS AND APPLSE]
>> Greg: T DARK IAD.
TH'S WHERE GET MY BRAZIAN.
>> Dana: DIDOU A YOUR
PANTS FIRST?
>>yrus: YOUR FOUT.YOU WALK INTI.
>> Greg: IL TRANYTHING.
>>yrusSO THE NEXT TIME,
KIDS, YOU HEARIS